comes to go resumes they have something
very exciting to show you bros eres and
it's not this pumpkin face I look so
sassy I'm like a pity pig wait wait what
is this
how's it going Brad and my own drugs
open your eyes damn it aah oh my god
it's so cold
hey how's it going bros my name is bear
yeah yeah see I don't need to make
videos anymore I could just have this
guy go over it's amazing
my name's bonafide do you want me to
brofist yeah go admit it brofist you do
you want me to brofist you Oh brofist
you all right aah whoa those ice damn I
just saw my soul the hell hey how you
doing buddy that's great I have a
debugger so I have any space boogers
this is so weird
like phase Rick wasn't weird enough like
now right now it's just yeah hey uh my
name's Bob uh no Jesus what I can there
why what's for that what am i doing that
[ __ ] was grab you little bit Oh
my name is Paula pot that's all I can
say it badly
oh what a fresh brofist you're like when
I broke fits you like that I'll put it
by I will eat your soul [ __ ] may kiss
me sorry I just had some LSD don't worry
about it how's it going bros my name is
boo bah
sorry I'm a little sleepy sorry I better
wake up for this video I am putting
Polamalu I'm sorry I miss ya as ya been
yeah video for pot [ __ ] hell there's
the face look there we go i calibrated
it
hahaha smoke ray sucking no martinis
like you wanted me calling beaver
oh whoa whoa I can hear my service oh my
god it taught look it does the eyebrows
even how [ __ ] cool is that
how ah debit that's on me
uh oh it's so tiresome to be me people
don't realize what I have to go through
to be ah so so hard to be put at I'm an
AB I like my sideburns there hein
no but seriously this is very awesome
you bros can check this out as well
living link in the description thanks to
faze rig for for making me in their game
I think that's really cool of them to do
I hope you guys enjoyed this video
subscribe to become a brute today and as
always stay awesome right